this is a big day for me i've been
waiting for this day for almost two
years since you made your debut because
once we got chris sims i thought hey
it's just a matter of time before we get
phil sims and we have him today he's the
super bowl 21 mvp still the highest
completion percentage of any super bowl
quarterback he is phil sims and he joins
us now phil how are you buddy i'm doing
well mike uh christopher i'm doing well
too you woke me up out of a really good
sleep oh that's one thing and you know
look i always wanted to come on the show
but i wanted to wait till christopher
got comfortable it just took him two
years to get comfortable so now i'm
ready
he's not comfortable yet but
what you're supposed to say you're
supposed to say dad we want mike here
in the studio in nbc when we do it we
gotta you i want to pile it on mike but
when we're all three together i think
that would be perfect uh and we could
have yeah
yeah i will agree usually i disagree
with my son a lot of things but if we're
going to do it one day we all have to be
together because i think that just makes
it more fun well we will do that i'm not
moving to connecticut but one of the
days that i'm up there will get you over
to the studio and we will have a lot of
fun and phil we've we've had a lot of
fun trying to figure out exactly where
the nfl is heading with this length of
schedule and your comments from the
other day when i saw the transcript i
did a double take because you're the
first one that i've seen come out with a
very clear strong message that you
believe the players want 18 games i've
been conditioned to believe based on
hearing what the nfl players association
has to say that players don't want 18
games so you know this is kind of a
thing now it's kind of getting some
traction and we wanted to bring you on
and talk a little bit more about it
just set the stage for why you think
that that this is something that players
ultimately at the end of the day will
say we want 18 games no i don't know if
they'll say we want 18 games i probably
misspoke a little and i said it i said i
think they will
and you know i was having a nice quiet
offseason then i said that now i got
people texting me the nfl pa association
is sending me messages telling me to
shut up and on and on
but you know i look at it many ways it's
what coming up in three years
um it's all about we know the networks
all want 18 games we know the nfl wants
18 games i heard you guys yesterday
complaining about preseason games i love
pre-season football last year i was like
wow it is so bad that i can't even watch
it anymore but i look at this if you put
it up to a vote this is why i said it to
the players in the locker room each
player
now i don't know i didn't look at salary
caps or anything like that but if you
take let's just say the bottom 30
players on the payroll do you think they
don't want a couple more paychecks and
then also look at it this way
if you're the players association and
the nfl is just beating you over the
head they need these 18 games for many
many reasons one because of pre-season
play more excitement everybody wants it
as you as you do that um
what do the players do they have an
unbelievable bargaining chip and that
bargaining chip the the owners will give
up many things oh you don't want to
practice as much during the off season
we'll cut it down to two weeks we'll do
this and and i think the players will
get a bigger piece of the pie if they
decide to go those two
extra games not just normal game checks
but more more will be put into the
players what they receive and what the
nfl receives so those are just a couple
reasons i know that
i hate to even say it when i played i
think without question the players go oh
more money we're going to go for it but
the money is so big now i think it
changes the equation a little bit but i
just think of that bottom group of
players
and i i don't know if y'all agree with
me or not they would love to have to
have a couple more game checks each year
well okay dad so now off of that do you
worry about you know the the guys future
of their careers does this take away
from that is it going to hurt the
quality of playoffs you know i worry
about that that we get in the playoffs
and you know just like the nba finals
last night it's kawhi leonard limping
it's clay thompson out it's kevin durant
out and all of a sudden the quality of
play is not as good there what about
that aspect of it well we're going to
have less wear and tear preseason
offseason i guess if you want i want to
make that argument training camps will
you know be different than they are now
preseason games whether you lose a lot
of players cut those down and and also
you know
and i know and mike i've heard my son
say it well nfl football and i say it
almost every single year if you can
survive the first four or five weeks
you know you're in good hands because
the game slows down when everybody the
season starts everybody's in such great
shape they're as strong and as fast as
they're going to be the whole year and
those games i remember just going oh my
gosh that's when we played preseason too
right they were just so physical so fast
and you got beat up so much but once
your body gets in the groove and trained
to keep practicing taking these hits
then i think it becomes less i don't
know if the statistics bear that out
probably should have looked it up but it
seems to me like less players get hit
hurt as the year goes along so just
another thought it's not a fact usually
i like to have facts but i didn't have
time to look it up well hey phil and
here's how i interpret what you're
saying and i agree with it if this is
what you mean that regardless of what
the players want the owners clearly want
it one of the things you said on chris's
podcast the other day resonated with me
when you have an owner come up to you at
practice and say why do you hate us why
are you so against us right because it's
they are determined to get to 18. it
will not go away no matter what the
players association says about not
wanting it i get the impression the
league is dead set on getting to 18 and
anytime roger goodell talks about
shrinking the preseason the deeper
message is yes and expanding the regular
season we won 18 games well well first
off when a couple high-ranking officials
in the league and owners say things to
me and i'm like
you know uh what do i say here you know
i'm kind of caught in a mind because i
was pretty strong that the i would not
want it done for the players but times
have changed
and the biggest thing is mike how much
money do you need
what's the answer you need more
so that's right
and so these players and and that and
and the owners everybody involved knows
it's bigger we all know that football is
the biggest thing on tv and here we are
here you guys for a whole offseason
when no games are going on you're
talking about the games and players and
sits all that the whole offseason every
tv show you turn on still talks about
football so um fans i was in an event
two nights ago well i can't wait for the
season this what do you think what do
you think i said well let me wait till
august i started talking about the
upcoming season and i i just think
again
that the bargaining ship the players
have they did a good job last time
getting practices turned down
time limits uh less time at the
facilities during the off season uh some
of those things they'll probably even
get more and i know the coaches i hate
it but you know what the owners are
going to say to the coaches well
everybody's got the same rules so just
deal with it right and um so it'll be
it's still a long way away
and
again
if the
the bargaining goes the way the players
association would want it to go then i
just think there's a very good chance
it'll happen dad so players are gonna
say you know all right two more games
you're increasing my injury risk right
you know i'm already worn out at the end
of the year you're gonna add two more
games on you know after an eight year
career if you're playing 18 games it's
really a nine to your career for guys
this day and age right so
let's just say what is the number dad
what's the number you think that's good
if a player's making 1.6 million dollars
what's the number that you think is
gonna get the players to go okay uh now
you've added this to my 1.6 i'll play i
don't think it's just going to be 1.8 i
mean is it going to be
okay what do you think it'll be
like i said
they have so many things to bargain with
and to get them the nfl knows it's going
to be making more money and i don't know
about the networks how much money more
money they can make when it comes to
selling and paying for these big bills
but
the owners have it means more money than
them so they're going to be a little
more generous in giving some of that
away because they know the extra is
coming in yeah so if you're making one
six i don't know what would it be what
would it do for you yeah right
i think it'll be something where you
just go wow that is a lot of money right
because let's don't forget
we're thinking you're thinking about all
the guys that make so much money that
they don't care but that's not the way
it is with most of the players in the
league they are smart enough to know if
everything goes right i can get a
five-year career out of this right and
that money is not big and an extra
paycheck or two is a big deal to him
right so that that was my argument and
one of my reasons and look years ago
when i first did a game over in london
one of the first ones i said oh my gosh
there's going to be football over here
within five years well i was wrong uh
but i still do believe one day it's
coming and uh i think this is gonna be a
very interesting
bargaining time
for the players association in the nfl
when it comes up
hey phil i got one more question for you
and this is something that i think the
nfl will say to the union when it's time
to make the case for 18. they will come
in with clips
of games played during your era in the
80s on green cement before the rules
were changed to make the game safer i
went back and watched just a little bit
of a game from 1987 vikings 49ers nfc
divisional round game and it's
astounding how much more brutal the game
was and i think the game really has been
made dramatically safer over the last 30
years and that supports the argument
hey if we could do 16 under those
conditions 18 under today's rules as a
walk in the park
well yes you know the game is more
spread out now and uh you know speed is
a bigger factor um you know we played
the game was closer tighter but probably
more physical i think i said to my
christopher one day probably a couple
weeks ago i said do you ever
remember me getting a a roughing the
passer call did they ever call roughing
the passengers
and you know i'm almost serious i'm
really serious i i you could throw the
ball and the guy would run with it for
10 yards then you get wiped out from
behind by reggie white or somebody else
like that
i just don't remember late hits and of
course some of the hits we took nowadays
would be six game suspensions uh if you
did it to the quarterback but you know
that's the old news but i think the nfl
has done a great job
of
protecting players changing rules to
keep it going and you know everybody
complain oh it won't look the same on tv
man when i watch it i still find it as
exciting as ever so it'll be interesting
to see what happens but it it's three
years a long way away and um
being in the business i just hope they
they come to an agreement where we don't
run a football season
well phil hopefully it's sooner than
three years that we have you back on the
program i look forward to the day that
three of us can do it i just don't want
to be caught between the two of you i
know how chris i know what chris does to
me i figure i'll be getting it from both
sides
between the two he listens to the
podcast you know i i just i go on and
try to get him you know
don't worry about that well maybe that's
good you and i can gang up in him i'm
talking more about physically though
chris likes to lay hands on he likes to
grab
those big old mitts he does it to me too
i say look man i'm an old man now get
off of me
it used to be the day i was the
intimidator now they walk around me
don't touch me
no don't touch me i'm in this stage i'm
in preservation mode
you know
not only that and you know when you two
do your picks and your list and stuff
and you know i love my son but damn son
you're embarrassing you're losing almost
everyone oh thanks dad
we've had enough of you get out of here
thanks phil
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports